you're 19 years old
whose house do you get to go over for
dinner what was the greatest night where
you all of a sudden you get a call and
you say we want to have you over this
would be great well
elton john
said he wanted us to have dinner and he
has a he has a chef that he that that
helps him and and makes food for him and
is is really sweet and
throughout the night and he's such a
he's so sweet and his house is huge
sure billy and i went over to dinner at
elton's house
david furnish and in the kitchen out
would come these really delicious dishes
and he also had a sort of uh for lack of
a maybe the perfect word he had a
manservant butler person named bumble
and he would he would over the course
the evening he'd be in the middle of
telling you a story and he'd say oh
sorry one second bubble and he would
shout like that and and and bumble
literally oliver twist and this very
sweet man would scurry in kind of sort
of head bowed and elton would go um
could you can i have a cappuccino please
at like 10 p.m yeah and bumble would nod
and elton would look to me and he'd go
uh do you want anything and i'd go um
yeah i'd also take whatever the same
thing you'll have i'll have a cappuccino
too and then you'd be in the middle of
it he'd be telling you know some other
incredible unbelievable elton john-esque
story yeah and he'd be in the middle of
it you go hold on bumble and bubble
bringing like his heartburn medication
on like a little silver
planet
so great it was great
you